- Okay, if an asteroid
were coming to hit earth.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Like the movies.
- How would we stop it?
I mean, this is possible, right?
- Oh yes, so.
We know exactly how to stop it.
- He knows the answer right!
- No, no, no, it's only
two ways you can stop it.
One of them is the macho way.
- Blow it up?
- Blow the sucker out of the sky.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- I'm from the south.
(laughing)
- You uttered all those--
- -[Kelly] Shoot it!
- Oh yeah, shoot the
sucker out of the sky!
- Who cares what the
ramifications to the rest of
the universe are.
- This is what I'm saying.
- Yeah.
- In America, we now blow stuff
up, but we don't always know
where the pieces go!
'cause we blow it up,
now can have two parts
that are gonna hit.
All the pieces, what's gonna happen?
So kind of a gentler
way is you go up there
and you nudge it out of harms way.
If you get there early
enough, you nudge it a little,
that accumulates and then
it misses earth entirely.
- What are you nudging it with?
- That's a good question!
(laughing)
- Excuse me!
- An astronaut goes up there
and goes, "There we go."
(laughing)
- So there are ways you
can do it gravitationally,
what we call a gravitational tether.
So you have another object
and they attract each other,
and so as they attract each other--
- Like a magnet?
- Well, like with gravity, so, yeah.
Gravity.
- A gravity tether.
- Gravity tether.
- Gravity tether, that's
what, I knew that.
You should explain it to her, I know!
(laughing)
- So they attack each
other but then this object
you put up there has
rockets in that pulls aside,
and they still attract
each other and it slowly
drags it out of harms way.
There will be a gravitational action.
- That would have been a
much easier answer than
all those movies.
- Yeah.
- Then you don't get to flood
New York and stuff like that.
- Right, right.
- Well it would have to be fun too!
- So here's the twist--
- Or you could just blow it up!
- We know how to do it
from an engineering point,
but there is no funded project
in the world to actually
make that happen.
So we are just sitting ducks!
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- I'm fretting ain't it great!
(laughing)
- Sorry we're all gonna die!
- He's kidding!
- Who am I kidding.
- We need you to become engineers
so you can solve this problem.
- Yes that's right!
(clapping)
- [Kelly] With gravitational tether.